listen i know that kelly clarkson is
doing well but when her soon-to-be
ex-husband thinks it's reasonable to
request
nearly 500 000 a month from her
well it's kind of mind-blowing still it
wasn't about the money when kelly
addressed her divorce on her talk show
today
[Music]
it's horrible there are so many hard
parts
the hardest for me is the kids that's
the hardest for me
i think as women especially we're
trained to take it all on and you can
deal with it and you're fine
but it's your babies that you worry
about trust issues
a custody battle and now e.t has
confirmed that brandon blackstock wants
kelly to pay him
436 thousand dollars a month 301
000 of that would be for spousal support
the remaining 135 grand would be for
kids
remy and river brandon also wants 2
million for attorney's fees
kelly clarkson kelly seemed unfazed by
all the divorce drama that's playing out
in the headlines
as the voice began live shows last night
and gwen's engagement ring
made its tv debut gwen stole
from her fiancee it's official now we're
live
after the show gwen blake kelly and john
did a socially distant
drive-through red carpet complete with
vintage cars
i guess of the four coaches i'm most
worried about gwen
getting behind the wheel having said
that almost a few seconds ago slammed
this truck
into the front end of the pink cadillac
that she's driving
feels incredible to be back here for the
lives i'm excited about the labs this
year we're really lucky we get to have
live music
america is going to have a tough
decision just minutes earlier
this stunning twist on the live show as
a side note team kelly's ryan gallagher
had to exit the competition
[Music]
what happened et has learned that the
classically trained vocalist
broke the voice's strict coveted
protocols and wasn't allowed to continue
on the show